you can't do the evil thing you can't oh
can't I because evil is bad but what if
I told you it advances my interests
mainly money and power I'd say that's
pretty evil then I guess I'm evil hit it
Boys 2 three I'm evil and I love it you
can't do the evil thing you cannot what
if I told you that your entire worldview
has been shaped by your ignorance and
privilege you live in a bubble designed
to protect those who harm the many I'm
neither motivated by power nor
Acquisitions of wealth but by a
steadfast belief in a cause in a faith
that one day the world may not be so
cruel so hateful
so
unjust I never thought I'd say this
but I understand you thank
you hitter Boys 2 three I'm evil and I
love
it